mesdames messieurs bonjour madame
Rousseau enchantée monsieur Vanet nous
sommes ravis de vous accueillir et nous
vous remercions d'avoir répondu
positivement à cette demande merci donc
d'avoir répondu à notre invitation pour
échanger sur la question importante de
l'autre
cette audition qui fait l'objet d'un
compte-rendu public qui sera publié sur
le site du Sénat vise à éclairer les
membres de la mission d'information sur
la gestion durable de l'eau lancé par le
Sénat début février à la demande du
groupe socialiste avec comme rapporteur
Monsieur Hervé gilet
cette mission comprend des sénateurs
représentants l'ensemble des groupes
politiques et devrait achever ces
travaux d'ici l'été
dans ce dans ce temps court il s'agit
pour nous d'entendre les experts les
parties prenantes et les acteurs
institutionnels de la politique de l'eau
en France le changement climatique
conduit à mettre sous tension l'ensemble
des utilisateurs de l'eau on l'a vu avec
la sécheresse estivale 2022 et la
sécheresse hivernale 2023 qui risque
d'entraîner une situation pire encore
il s'agit pour nous de prendre en compte
cette nouvelle donne climatique et
d'évaluer la pertinence de la politique
publique de l'eau menée aujourd'hui dans
notre pays tendant ses aspects
quantitatifs que qualitatif
nous attendons aujourd'hui votre clé est
éclairage pardon sur les transformations
du cycle de l'eau et les perspectives
que nous avons à une ou deux décennies
en effet votre stratégie scientifique
sur 10 ans qui définit les priorités de
recherche associées aux grands enjeux
socio-équipe économiques liés au sol et
au sous-sol notamment la gestion des
eaux souterraines nous aiderons à
répondre plus ou moins directement aux
différentes questions posées à la
mission donc je vais vous laisser avec
le rapporteur qui lui a certainement un
grand nombre de questions
bien merci madame la Présidente chez
Evelyne pour ses propos intraduction
je vous remercie mes collègues aussi
d'être présents donc vous avez compris
la trajectoire qui est la nôtre
aujourd'hui
sachant que nous sommes dans une période
assez particulière qui en l'occurrence
donne une résonance à nos travaux sur un
certain nombre d'interrogations avec en
perspective à venir une annonce
gouvernementale sur la planification
j'ai pas encore d'éléments factuels pour
savoir quand est-ce que c'est cette
communication
éminente nous sera faite et bien sûr on
essaiera à la fois de s'éclairer et
peut-être d'éclairer certains sujets à
ce niveau là alors il est vrai que la
situation hivernale est déjà
particulièrement inquiétante aujourd'hui
donc elle nous amène sans doute à
approfondir un certain nombre de sujets
on vous a transmis donc la liste des
questions donc je vais vous proposer de
prendre parole à partir de celle-ci je
vais me permettre peut-être
d'insister sur
quelques sujets
bien sûr on pourra pas faire autrement
que d'aborder la question des bassines
puisque ce sujet est un sujet qui
questionne qui questionne aussi
juridiquement vous l'avez compris et qui
est de nature conflictuelle même sur le
plan scientifique si on y regarde d'un
peu plus près donc il a un sujet
particulier à approfondir et puis une
question aussi qui n'est pas
inintéressante sur le rôle des forêts
dans le stockage souterrain de l'eau et
inversement sur la capacité des forêts à
pomper l'eau puisque au travers des feux
hors normes que l'on nous avons connu
notamment en Gironde et dans le massif
forestier landais un peintre consommé 50
100 parfois plus de litres d'eau par
jour et donc ce qui était démarré hier
peut redevenir des marais demain si bien
sûr les plantations ne sont pas mises en
oeuvre on va dire assez rapidement et
quand on parle de ces plantations il y a
aussi la nature des plantations
qui se pose aujourd'hui
voilà juste quelques propos liminaires
et puis je vais vous laisser la parole
pour
vous amener à répondre sur les questions
qu'on a pu qu'on a pu vous poser je vous
remercie
nous reprenons les questions
donc sur les quantités d'eau
exploitables dans dans les eaux dans les
eaux souterraines
c'est une question qui est pas si facile
que ça en terme de réponse parce que ça
signifie ré qu'on connaisse avec
précision la quantité d'eau stockée dans
dans les nappes souterraines c'est pas
tout à fait le cas on connaît
l'existence des nappes leur superficie
on connaît déjà moins bien leur
épaisseur vous voyez et également la
quantité d'eau contenue dans une nappe
qui dépend de la porosité en fait du
matériau rocheux qui contient l'eau
n'est pas toujours connu avec précision
donc pour le BRGM donner le stock n'est
pas quelque chose de très facile par
contre nous arrivons plus facilement à
chiffrer la recharge ce qui fait que
avec un principe de précaution on
considère souvent qu'il vaut mieux ne
pas prélever plus que ce qui a été
rechargé parce que sinon quelque part on
se dit on doit on doit consommer le
stock ce que je dis est très schématique
parce qu'une nappe va s'écouler un peu
comme une rivière simplement beaucoup
plus lentement donc
localement oui
à l'échelle globale en fait ça assez peu
de sens de parler du volume du stock
puisque ce qui est important c'est le
stock disponible ou l'eau qui est
potentiellement exploitable alors
proximité des bassins consommation
et dans ces cas où il y a des personnes
consommation sur des secteurs qui
peuvent être en tension il est
effectivement nécessaire de pouvoir
modéliser très précisément le stock le
stock dehors c'est ce qui est fait dans
déjà pas mal d'endroits on a mis en
évidence également qu'il y a une
vingtaine de bassin versants en France
qui mériterait d'avoir des modèles
beaucoup plus précis de gestion de l'eau
pour qu'on connaisse parfaitement le
stock et qu'on puisse définir des
scénarios de politiques de l'eau qui
permettent une gestion pérenne
finalement de la ressource qu'on est
toujours de l'eau en quantité en qualité
suffisante au moins pour la population
en alimentation en eau potable alors des
prélèvements sont de l'ordre de 6
milliards de mètres cubes par an quand
même avec des stocks dont on peut on
peut trouver dans des documents un
chiffre de de 100 milliards de mètres
cubes mais c'est très approximité quand
on parle de six milliard je vais mettre
cubes prélevé parce qu'on entend
beaucoup de choses actuellement dans les
médias c'est évidemment dans les eaux
souterraines déjà et or hors énergie
voilà c'est on parle vraiment de l'eau
prélevé pour l'industrie pour
l'agriculture et pour l'eau potable dans
les dans les nappes c'est issus de la
Banque Nationale des prélèvements alors
on estime que ces chiffres sont
légèrement sous-évalués puisqu'il y a
probablement pas mal depuis non déclarés
qui pompe un petit peu d'eau pour les
jardins pour les choses comme ça qui
augmentent un petit peu ce chiffre mais
voilà le son grosso modo c'est aussi
c'est 10 milliards de prélèvements dans
les eaux souterraines pour les
consommations courantes et industrielles
par an
très bien juste pour clôturer peut-être
ce premier sujet du coup sur la
connaissance approfondie de des
capacités de stockage des nappes
notamment sur les bassins qui sont en
tension
donc ça serait un objectif mais comment
peut-il se réaliser ce que vous avez les
moyens de le faire est-ce qu'il faudrait
accélérer c'est un objectif mais qui
peut être réalisé à l'échelle locale
c'est-à-dire que la bonne échelle de la
gestion de louche c'est bassin versant
du pays ça n'a pas de sens et
effectivement dans le contrat d'objectif
du BRGM qui vient d'être écrit pour les
quatre prochaines années je ne sais plus
une des un des objectifs principaux
c'est justement
de réaliser ces modèles de gestion de de
mettre en place des modèles de gestion
donc de connaître parfaitement la
ressource pour pouvoir scénariser les
ressources sur les bassins versants en
tension qui ne sont pas actuellement
gérés donc nous avons pour objectif
d'ici 5 ans d'arriver sur toutes les
attention à avoir d'une part des modèles
de prévisions du niveau du niveau des
nappes des modèles saisonniers de
prévision des niveaux des nappes et puis
des modèles de gestion avec des
scénarios pour regarder les conséquences
du changement climatique mais à la
question à votre question plus précise
est-ce qu'on saurait on saurait mesurer
l'épaisseur l'épaisseur d'une nappe ça
porosité avec des mesures géophysiques
oui bien sûr on serait tout à fait
capable localement d'arriver à connaître
l'épaisseur de la nappe et ensuite
d'estimer la porosité simplement ça
représenterait des moyens financiers il
faudrait qu'on puisse chiffrer et et
ceci serait à faire peut-être pas France
entière parce que ça pourrait être
coûter très cher
localement là où les problèmes les plus
importants se rencontrent de façon si
jamais les les on vit une période de
sécheresse et que les pubs les forages
sont dénoyés de répondre à une question
d'ailleurs que vous posez à savoir
est-ce qu'il suffit pas tout simplement
de forêt plus profond alors sans doute
trouver de l'eau en forêt plus profond
mais il faut faire attention de pas de
pas gérer l'eau comme une ressource non
renouvelable d'épuisée complètement le
stock et de se retrouver dans une
situation catastrophique dans dans
quelques temps
le résultat et d'autre part la durée de
renouvellement ou la durée pour laquelle
il faudrait permettre un rendez-vous
maintenant et beaucoup plus important
pour les nappes profondes donc mais ça
effectivement se modélise et il faut pas
donner une réponse dans l'absolué
très bien ça c'était donc peut-être pour
la première question on va parler de la
dégradation du niveau de remplissage
donc des mois dégradation du niveau de
remplissage des nappes alors les nappes
déjà pour de façon très schématique vous
avez des nappes réactive puisqu'ils sont
des nappes qui sont assez superficielles
et en communication avec avec les cours
d'eau et vous avez des nappes
inertiaires qui sont des nappes plus
profondes alors pour ce qui se passe à
l'heure actuelle c'est qu'on a à peu
près sur toute la France sauf le la
Manche et puis encore l'extrême
nord-ouest
vous avez actuellement des niveaux des
niveaux des nappes qui sont partout
plus bas que d'habitude c'est France
entière c'est ça qui est exceptionnel
parce qu'on a eu des
cet automne une recharge en hiver qui a
été insuffisante donc les nappes
inertiel qui dépendent des pluies
diables dont 4 mois sont touchés et puis
formidable très réactive qui dépendent
des plus du mois dernier sont également
sont également touchés donc actuellement
on va dire qu'on a 80% des nappes qui
sont en dessous du niveau normal des
nappes au mois de au mois de mars donc
c'est quand même très important l'an
dernier de la même époque c'était 50 %
là maintenant c'est 80 % alors qu'est-ce
qui peut se passer pour les nappes
inertiales donc les nappes passer
profondes
BRGM est assez pessimiste sur sur l'été
parce qu'il faudrait qu'il pleuve
énormément pour pouvoir attraper
faudrait qu'il y ait des puits
décennales ou plus pour pouvoir
progresser d'un cran je n'ai pas
retrouvé une situation normale mais
progresser d'un cran pour les nappes qui
sont très réactives superficielles ça va
dépendre de la pluie des des pluies des
prochains mois c'est encore faisable
mais on peut pas on peut pas le savoir
je vais essayer d'entraîner
sachant que tous les végétaux sont en
pleine croissance aujourd'hui donc de
toute manière
ça va quand même largement limiter
oui il faudrait qu'il pleuve
effectivement beaucoup dans la partie
nord de la France on a encore une petite
quinzaine de jours où on peut quand même
espérer que s'il pleut beaucoup la
recherche se fasse correctement dans le
sud le cycle végétatif est déjà parti
donc ça pompe un petit peu plus et puis
une partie de votre question je pense
porter sur le plus long terme
alors sur les nappes inertiales ça n'a
pas de sens de réfléchir sur lesquels
qu'elle n'a pour baisse à long terme
puisque comme on l'a dit elle se peuvent
se remplir et se vider en quelques mois
donc dès qu'il commence à pleuvoir
beaucoup c'est des nappes qui se
remplissent c'est les nappes par exemple
du Centre Ouest de la France pour les
nappes après actives et réactiver
excusez-moi bon après actif pour les
nappes inertiels
on n'a pas de temps de nappe que ça qui
sur le long terme sont structurellement
en baisse il y en a une qui me vient en
tête naturellement c'est la nappe de la
Beauce dont on constate depuis une bonne
vingtaine d'années que petit à petit les
plus haut niveau sont de plus en plus
bas même si on est encore un stock qui
est conséquent mais il n'empêche que la
tendance est à la baisse on a quelques
nappes dans le sud de la France
notamment en Provence ou dans le
Sud-Ouest où on commence à constater des
de pareil de pareil tendance mais dans
les grandes lignes les nappes connectées
en tout cas avec la surface la plus
grande en France étant évidemment la
nappe de la craie
arrive encore à avoir des des recharges
suffisamment conséquentes maintenant ce
sont des nappes inertiels qui sont
cycliques sur plusieurs années et là
c'est vrai qu'actuellement on est dans
un cyclo où c'est naps sur 4 5 6 7 ans
on constate une baisse maintenant on a
on n'a pas constaté de baisse sur sur 20
ou 30 ans qui nous permet de dire que
structurellement c'est nappes sont en
baisse et puis on a quelques nappes
beaucoup plus profondes des nappes qui
sont qui ont des recherches très
complexes qui ont des recherches très
très longues parfois plusieurs centaines
d'années ou alors je pense à la nappe du
Carbonifère qui alimente à la fois la
Wallonie et la Flandre et le nord de la
France du côté de l'île où
structurellement on a également des
baisses de niveau de nappe sur le long
terme alors là encore les volumes
restants sont très conséquents mais
effectivement il peut on constate c'est
une surexploitation par rapport à la
capacité de de remplissage de la nappe
merci on a un petit peu abordé
l'objectif d'évaluation et de contrôle
peut-être qu'on peut glisser par rapport
à la question 3 sur les calculer les
niveaux normaux de nappe
la question 4 elle pose la question de
la stratégie aussi pour améliorer la
recharge en fait
donc ça c'est des questions assez
fondamentales que nous essayons de créer
aussi dans le cas de ce qu'on appelle
les politiques d'urbanisme en fait on
pousse peut-être la réflexion pour voir
comment on peut mieux intégrer
aujourd'hui la gestion de l'eau dans les
politiques d'urbanisme que ce soit
l'échelle des codes des Scotts et des
pluies et donc une meilleure gestion
aussi du fil de l'eau et donc par
ailleurs des zones humides c'est un peu
sous-jacent de cette question 4 qui vous
est posée sur comment on peut améliorer
les stratégies en fait
je pense qu'on peut on peut le monde à
cette question d'un point de vue
qualitatif on voit bien qu'il faut
essayer de désimperméabiliser des sols
d'avoir moins de sol à nu avec de la
végétation qui faut avoir des nous des
fossés il faut retenir l'eau un peu des
zones humides retenir l'eau en surface
pour qu'elle puisse s'infiltrer bien
entendu dans les nappes donc ça
qualitativement c'est le faire il y a
également des des localement de la
recharge maîtrisée des nappes mais sont
toujours de la recherche maîtrisée de
nappes superficielles donc donna
pré-active grâce à ces techniques de
fossés de zone humide et on ça permet
aussi de filtrer l'eau qui est assez
rapidement récupéré pour pour l'eau
potable là où on ne on est un peu en
limite c'est pour arriver à quantifier
les conséquences de ces techniques si
vous voulez sur sur les nappes si on
désimperméabilise dans une métropole par
exemple
quels sont les conséquences précises sur
le niveau des nappes ça est encore du
domaine de la recherche on a quelques
travaux en cours on a des travaux en
cours le plus important étant sur une
métropole européenne de l'île où on
appartenariat de recherche développement
avec eux pour justement quantifier enfin
voir quelles sont les meilleurs moyens
de désimperméabilisation quels sont les
meilleures politiques de d'aménagement
urbain qui sont possibles de prendre
pour améliorer et la quantité et la
qualité de la nappe de la crèche
sous-jacente donc on teste plusieurs
choses effectivement des zones de dés
imperméabilisation donc revégétalisation
présence de nous on teste aussi des des
tentatives de déconnexion de réseau par
exemple maintenant que les réseaux d'eau
pluvial est déconnecté du réseau d'eau
usé les eaux pluviales avec des
traitements simples pourraient être
réinjectés on pourrait tout simplement
servir à des à des arrosages de de parc
de stade ou de choses comme ça qui
permet aussi d'éviter de de pomper de
trop donc c'est tout un tas de tests
qu'il faut faire qu'on modélise alors ça
nécessite d'avoir des données
extrêmement fines donc des données sur
les prélèvements des données sur
sur la sur la géologie et qui nous
permet de pouvoir presque avoir un
jumeau numérique de la de la de la
réalité physique et de ce fait on peut
ainsi modéliser les impacts des
politiques publiques d'urbanisme qui
pourrait être mise en œuvre et voir
l'impact sur sur la ressource et dans
les zones dont les zones pureurales on
sait que par exemple un sol qui a été
très labouré va moins bien retenir
va s'opposer en fait un infiltration à
l'infiltration des de l'eau donc tout
est technique qui permettent de se
passer de la bourre on le meilleur
meilleur
impact et puis alors sur un sujet qui
est polémique dans le domaine de l'eau
sur les sujets des obstacles et des
seuils dans les Rhodos les rivières
alors quand il y a des seuils l'eau
stagne un peu et donc ça s'infiltre
d'avant
c'est moins bien pour les pour la
circulation des poissons c'est meilleur
c'est un sujet qui met toujours mais
toujours en débat le Sénat tout entier
entre la vision patrimoniale des seuils
et des moulins et puis la continuité
écologique mais on va pas rouvrir chers
collègues le débat parce qu'on parle de
nappe j'en profite
demeurer un peu j'insiste sur un point
sur les murs évidemment le but est de
réinfiltrer le plus possible c'est pas
c'est pas sans risque c'est à dire que
l'eau on a des cycles donc des cycles de
sécheresse mais il y a aussi il y en
aura encore des cycles de surplus d'eau
et notamment d'inondation par remontées
de Naples et il y a des secteurs qui
sont très sensibles remonter de nappe
donc
voilà c'est on peut pas avoir de
politique généraliste sur le sujet
l'idée c'est de faire la meilleure chose
au bon endroit et tout ça nécessite
d'être correctement pris en compte à la
fois par des modèles de scénario mais
aussi par l'étude des risques associés
c'est en lien également avec le
pronostic de retrait gonflement des
argiles notamment si on plante des armes
parce qu'on sait que les arbres enfin
voilà à proximité de de maison on peut
générer du testement différentiel
générer des fissurations de maison enfin
bref il y a tout un tas de d'éléments
qui sont mettre du bon sens pour pour
garder l'eau ou pour revégétaliser les
centres urbains et qui par effet de
conséquences pour avoir des des risques
importants donc tout l'enjeu est de
trouver le bon équilibre entre ces
bénéfices et
quant au milieu ruraux effectivement le
nom labour a fait ses preuves
l'ennerbement la remise en place de
haies fait ses preuves avec des des
capacités d'infiltration qui peuvent
être multipliées par 30 dans les zones
où on remet des on voire même quand on
quand on passe sur dans la bourse à
noter quand même que les pratiques
culturelles ont beaucoup évolué dans ce
sens depuis maintenant une bonne
vingtaine d'années notamment depuis la
mise en place des cultures
intermédiaires pièges à nitrates sur la
sur la période d'automne
ou finalement la croûte de battances est
beaucoup moins importante qu'avant
puisque les terres sont végétalisées à
des époques où elles ne l'était plus les
problèmes qu'on rencontre en ce moment
sont essentiellement sur les cultures de
printemps donc au printemps dans les
terres riches comme vous pouvez avoir en
Normandie elle était le sick où on a
très rapidement sur les on a de plus en
plus d'orages de printemps aux périodes
où les terres sont nues parce que les
cultures de printemps se sème au cours
du mois de mars avril et que les terres
sont encore mieux en mec en quand
arrivent les orages et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on a vraiment du mal à gérer
donc qui est gérable par la mise en
place de bande es en herbées par exemple
de haies par la mise en place de fascine
dans les zones les plus contributives
mais c'est le principal c'est la
principale période de problème qu'on
contractuellement en zone rurale
donc c'est des sujets effectivement qui
sont importants on en est conscient
peut-être pour refroidir l'atmosphère
sachez que au niveau des haies on a
plutôt régressé ces dernières années que
augmentaient donc vous voyez que c'est
un sujet qu'il faut oui malgré les
malgré les aides les aides européens
aussi voilà donc maintenant on essaie de
replanter mais même malgré les les
efforts d'accompagnement ces dernières
années on a plutôt régressé là-dessus
mais c'est des stratégies qu'il faut
essayer d'inscrire à différents niveaux
peut-être juste pour clôturer ce
chapitre du coup
essayons d'idéaliser mais on pourrait au
niveau des réseaux séparatifs
aujourd'hui imaginez les réseaux de
demain qui permettent d'utiliser aussi
le pluvial à bon escient pour
reconstituer à la fois soit des zones
humides ou des zones d'infiltration etc
et inscrire donc ces évolutions de
réseaux pluvial aujourd'hui dans le
schéma directeur qui doit s'inscrire
dans un PLU ou plu par exemple
toujours en pensant à la gestion du
risque associé donc ça nécessite souvent
des microstations de traitement à
l'endroit où on va réutiliser l'eau
pluviale pour que pour que de l'eau brut
parfois qui peut être un petit peu
pollué n'arrive pas dans des endroits
qui n'étaient pas touchés par ces
pollutions
je commence à serrer les questions oui
donc on a vu mais un gros saut vous
n'avez donné quelques informations
pessimistes finalement sur le niveau
actuel des nappes souterraines on risque
d'avoir
dans toute la France
toute la France va être concerné
certainement rapidement y compris pour
des arrêtés de restriction d'eau alors
je sais que le BRGM a esquissé des
pistes comme par exemple recharger les
nappes d'eau
par des zones non conventionnelles y
compris des eaux de stations d'épuration
des eaux usées traitées alors on peut y
voir des avantages mais on peut avoir
aussi quelques questionnements donc moi
j'aimerais nous en disiez plus sur cette
piste là et puis lorsque l'eau était
vécu comme une source inépuisable on
parlait pas de priorisation des usages
moi j'aimerais avoir votre garçon
scientifique sur les quantités d'eau
quand il est d'autres sources qui sont
prélevées à des fins de
commercialisation
souvent en très grande quantité et qui
viennent diminuer de façon drastique la
quantité disponible pour une utilisation
locale avec évidemment des inquiétudes
légitimes pour l'avenir
alors sur la sur la deuxième question
donc les os pour faire prélever pour des
eaux minérales et autres donc là alors
déjà évidemment c'est des préfets qui
fixent les seuils les seuils de
prélèvement et que l'eau soit utilisée
pour l'industrie ou qu'elle soit
utilisée pour autre chose ça pose la
question du calcul des volumes
prélevables donc le BRGM est assez peu
sollicité quand même par par les préfets
pour pour aider aux calculs de ces
volumes prélevables c'est un constat et
comme je le disais tout à l'heure on
connaît pas forcément très bien pour une
nappe le stock le stock d’eau de la
nappe et et sa dynamique de recharge
précise c'est à dire il faut bien
connaître la vitesse donc j'allais dire
de stock on arrive à mesurer la recharge
naturelle par les plus assez
correctement on connaît pas toujours
très bien les prélèvements les
prélèvements on les connaît en
de prélèvement ou le les prélèvements ne
dépassent pas ne dépasse pas la recharge
annuelle tout simplement j'imagine que
pour ce qui vous concerne c'est plutôt
Volvic mais c'est la ressource de du
côté du Puy-de-Dôme mais beaucoup moins
bien connu que ce que celle que je
prenne l'exemple dans l'Est de la France
alors que j'ai dit on vous donnera une
réponse écrite sur le sujet parce que je
ne l'ai plus en tête c'est un service de
l'État mais je ne sais plus lequel
c'était votre deuxième question la
première question revenez sur la façon
de faire de la recharge maîtrisée donc à
notre connaissance à recharge maîtrisée
en France et à peu près 2% des
prélèvements de grandeur ça ne se fait
que pour les nappes réactives donc des
dates très superficielles et plutôt
plutôt des utilisations de berges de
cours d'eau des choses ou des zones
humides est-ce que du côté des eaux
usées de station d'épuration alors on
reste à l'état de toute façon pour
l'instant de rechercher développement
pour le recharger la loi est pour
l'instant très stricte sur les eaux
usées donc
tant qu'elle n'évoluera pas on pourra
pas mettre de manière industrielle des
eaux usées dans le sous-sol maintenant
ça fait effectivement partie des choses
qu'on cherche à maîtriser pour le jour
où ce sera possible
on puisse le faire quoi qu'il arrive
la première attention ça reste d'envoyer
de ne pas dégrader la qualité et sans
respecte tout simplement la décès mais
de ne pas dégrader la qualité des eaux
souterraines donc il y a une étude
importante qui est faite sur la chimie à
différents termes de l'eau qui serait
qui serait injectée
sur très rapide il faut ça ça a du sens
et on utilise dans le mois suivant si
sinon on aura rechargé pour rien puisque
l'eau sera dans la saison
il n'existe pas notre connaissance en
France de de recharge maîtrisée de
nappes inertiel pour pour quelques mois
à l'avance voir quelques saisons vous
voyez pour recharger pour deux ans ou
trois ans avant
posé en prolongation vous avez entendu
parler des expérimentations
Lot-et-Garonne et Haute-Garonne sur les
recharges de nappe justement oui puisque
c'est nous qui les menons ce projet qui
s'appelle hergaronne donc là pour le
coup on est dans une appliqué très
réactif puisque c'est une app des
graphes de la de la Garonne enfin la
nappe alluviale de la Garonne le but est
de
de prendre l'eau finalement un surplus
en hiver de la Garonne même si cette
année on ira pas le droit mais et de via
un canal de trouver une zone
d'infiltration privilégiée pour que
quelques mois plus tard donc une fois
qu'elle aura traversé toutes les graves
cette même eau comme qui vient de la
Garonne qui était injecté dans les
viandes puissent soutenir le débit des
tirages de la Garonne donc ça c'est des
tests qu'on met actuellement on teste la
faisabilité technique on modélise ce qui
va se passer mais ça reste à l'étape
très expérimental pour pour le moment
par contre les
recharges maîtrisées des acouphènes
c'est quelque chose qui se fait
finalement depuis très longtemps c'est
quand même ce sont quand même des
techniques qui sont maintenant
relativement éprouvés et qu'on pourrait
mettre en oeuvre si tentait que on
trouve la solution utile et que ce soit
finalement sociétalement acceptable mais
en tout cas c'est techniquement c'est
des choses qui sont qui sont faisables
mais l'intérêt effectivement
il n'est que saisonnier sur mon plus
réelle il y a assez peu d'intérêt le but
finalement c'est de ce qu'on appelle de
d'avoir un effet retard de de
d'infiltrer l'autre de surplus hivernal
pour que la période des tiages et
surtout la fin de la période des tirages
donc août septembre on est 7 eau qui
arrive par les par les versants et qui
viennent soutenir le débit des tirages
par les nappes puisque en été ce qui ce
qui fait le débit des cours d'eau
notamment en milieu calcaire par exemple
c'est 80% de l'autre nappe qui qui se
vidange et qui soutient en début des
cours d'eau
quelques mots sur les haies
effectivement je crois que elles sont
maintenant bienvenue pour les
agriculteurs et ça fonctionne très bien
ça s'évalue même en centaines de
kilomètres de épeler chaque hiver
lorsque c'est accompagné lorsqu'il y a
un accompagnement financier et là la
région Normandie qui accompagné donc
l'implantation de haies et je peux vous
garantir que c'est c'est des centaines
de kilomètres qui ont été plantés cet
hiver donc c'est toujours voilà c'est
très bienvenu effectivement ça passe ça
passe d'autant mieux quand il y a
l'accompagnement financier qui vient en
parallèle forcément voilà et puis sur
les cultures de printemps alors là
je voulais revenir là-dessus
effectivement c'est des cultures qui
font partie d'une rotation
qu'elle laisse les sols nus tout dépend
du climat si vous avez un mois de mars
un peu sec effectivement ça va moins
bien partir que si on a beaucoup de
pluie il faut savoir qu'un enfin un
printemps normalement arrosé fait qu'on
a des lin par exemple sur une culture
d'un printemps d'ailleurs pour les
résumés c'est des betteraves c'est le
lin les cultures de printemps c'est le
l'escourgeons
ça ça peut ça peut faire 20 30 cm au
mois de mai sans aucun problème si c'est
correctement arrosé tout dépend en fait
de l'arrosage j'ai envie de vous dire
mais de dire qu'elle laisse les sols nus
je pense que c'est un petit peu
si c'est le temps qui se
l'idée d'aller
dire que qui compte est responsable de
quoi que ce soit
il s'avère pour parieur je connais très
bien agricole et que et que enfin voilà
les derniers gros problèmes de couler
debout qu'on a notamment dans la France
en Normandie vous êtes particulièrement
bien placé pour savoir faire plutôt côté
Seine-Maritime que côté je crois savoir
que vous êtes dans l'Eure mais mais on a
des on a effectivement des pas mal de
coulés de boue dans les hauts de France
dans dans
Seine-Maritime est dans l'heure les
dernières gros problèmes qu'on a en date
c'est c'est
Mimet début juin et ça concerne
essentiellement que ce soit ma culture
au printemps et en particulier les
pommes de terre la pomme de terre qui
est arrivée en force c'est 20 dernières
années notamment en haut de France alors
qu'ils demandent beaucoup d'eau mais
surtout qui est souvent cultivé dans le
sens de la pente qui bute donc il fait
des rigoles et qui a un vrai autoroute
finalement à ruissellement et donc qui
génère des coulés de bois c'est
importantes donc effectivement ne pose
pas trop de soucis alors je printemps
j'imagine c'est ça que vous vouliez
parler ne pose pas trop de pas trop de
soucis mais maïs pomme de terre dans une
moindre mesure betterave sont des
cultures qui sont quand même
génératrices de couler debout le jour on
a un orage au printemps et un des
problèmes et là c'est que le changement
climatique fait qu'on a une
intensification et une densification des
orages de printemps à des moments où les
seuls sont encore passent pas totalement
couverts puisque effectivement c'est les
cultures dont on parle couvrent pour les
premières comme les enjeux printemps
effectivement plutôt mi-avril début mai
mais pour les dernières comme les pommes
de terre et les betteraves surtout des
années on a pas beaucoup d'eau qui ont
tendance à couvrir plutôt au mois de
juillet
on repart nous sur notre cycle c'est bon
on peut avancer très bien je vous en
remercie
c'était juste un complément très rapide
par rapport à l'injection d'eau dans les
agrifères je me suis effectivement
renseigné sur sur ce que vous réessayez
de faire dans le Lot-et-Garonne on dit
que c'était déjà le une méthode utilisée
du temps des Romains au niveau de la de
la qualité de l'eau parce que finalement
c'est un stockage qu'on va chercher
aussi et on en parlait lors de notre
dernière audition dans un contexte on
essaie de remettre en place des bassines
qui sont quelque part des stockages de
surface là ni plus ni moins le bon sens
nous guide et nous dit qu'il vaut mieux
stocker l'eau en profondeur à l'abri de
l'évaporation et des pollution que
qu'autre chose mais est-ce qu'on envoie
de l'eau de bonne qualité qui a le temps
de se filtrer aussi est-ce qu'on ne
pollue pas quelque part la nappe en
termes de qualité et pas de quantité
alors il s'avère que cette nappe
d'accompagnement de la Garonne ce qui
l’alimente c'est l'eau de la Garonne et
là dans le test qu'on fait on
l'emprise et de l'eau de la Garonne
qu'on verra injecter donc on ne fait que
répéter le schéma naturel en l'aidant un
petit peu par contre vous posez une
question qui est juste dans d'autres cas
effectivement
il est nécessaire on est toujours dans
une dans une étude enfin c'est pour ça
que j'insiste sur le fait dans tout ce
qu'on fait et tout ce qu'on propose
comme solution l'étude du risque est
d'abord importante l'impact est d'abord
important et et de fait
dans des endroits où on injecterait de
l'eau qui ne correspond pas à la chimie
de sous-jacente il est nécessaire de
faire les études d'impact des études
chimiques physico-chimiques et
géochimiques nécessaires au préalable de
tout test bien sûr
très bien merci on va essayer de
progresser dans le questionnaire aborder
un sujet qui est peut-être un peu plus
délicat justement sur
au niveau
juridique aujourd'hui et puis par
rapport à l'acceptabilité des projets
donc vous êtes de plus en plus entre
guillemets sollicité peut-être parfois
instrumentalisé
et puis on voit émerger aujourd'hui des
problématiques au travers de décision
notamment des tribunaux administratifs
qui reviennent en fait sur parfois des
des études des bergm ce qui le cas
qui est cité aujourd'hui c'est sur les
eaux UGC en charentais et
Charente-Maritime où là il y a les
quantités de prélèvement ont été remises
en question malgré des études que vous
pouviez faire à l'appui la remarque elle
est d'ordre plus générale est-ce que
vous sentez monter en puissance
effectivement ces problématiques de
contentieux aujourd'hui et puis on a
tous un exemple bien sûr sainte Soline
aujourd'hui aussi au niveau des bassines
sur lesquelles il y a une forme de
guerre entre guillemets entre les
rapports scientifiques
sur l'eau et on s'attend à en avoir de
plus en plus au fil des décennies parce
qu'on pense qu'effectivement il va y
avoir ce réchauffement climatique et
donc l'eau va devenir un sujet central
dans beaucoup de régions donc ça c'est
c'est net comme je le disais tout à
l'heure nous ne sommes pas souvent
consultés pour l'instant par les préfets
sur le calcul des volumes prélevables
mais nous travaillons le BRGM va
travailler
je l'ai noté justement parce que ça ça
m'interroge quelque part pourquoi je
vais me remettre en perspective une des
voix qui peut aussi éventuellement se
dégager c'est surtout la maîtrise à
l'échelle des bassins justement de à la
fois la ressource disponible et les
quantités ensuite qui sont prélevées le
but du jeu c'est d'arriver à avoir une
clarification qui permettrait d'avoir
une responsabilisation d'autant plus
forte en fonction de ce degré de
connaissance et donc
dans notre futur contrat d'objectif qui
commence d'ailleurs cette année il est
prévu que nous assistions davantage les
préfets pour le calcul des volumes
prélevables mais nous partons d'une
situation où on le faisait finalement
assez peu dans le cas dans le cas
particulier de sainte solide parce que
parlons de ce cas de ce cas concret le
BRGM est intervenu pour le compte d'une
coopérative il était pas mais en accord
avec avec d'État et nous avons simulé à
la demande de cette coopérative nous
avons répondu juste à la question à la
question qui était posée qui était de
dire si j'avais si je cherchais si
j'avais construit ces 16 retenus tes
questions 16 retenus à des grandes
retenues en surface si je j'avais
construit ses retenues dans la dans la
décennie deux minutes 2010 est-ce que
dans cette décennie là il y aurait eu
une amélioration
j'allais dire des débits des débits des
cours d'eau en été et qu'est-ce qui
serait aussi passé en hiver et c'est à
cette réponse là à cette question là que
le BRGM a répondu en confiant et en
disant oui il y aurait eu une
amélioration en été si on avait pu
réaliser des des prélèvements en hiver
pour remplir les retenues on aurait
amélioré en été on a quantifié
l'ordre de grandeur de cette
amélioration on l'a fait avec un modèle
qui était calé sur les années 2000 2010
c'était le seul modèle d'ailleurs
existant il n'était pas calé sur les
années
2010-2020 mais la décennie 2000 2010
présenté quand même des alternances de
sécheresse en fait était une décennie
qui semblait à peu près
représentative d'une décennie entre
guillemets normale nous n'avons pas
simulé le les conséquences du
réchauffement climatique j'allais dire
et
voilà et nous n'avons pas non plus dit
que on pouvait nécessairement réaliser
des prélèvements en hiver nous avons
nous avions un cahier des charges on
nous demandait une simulation à nous
fixant les prélèvements en hiver en nous
fixant les prélèvements en été et en
nous disant ça donne dites nous ce que
ça donne sur les débits des cours d'eau
de berger m'a répondu à cette question
et je pense qu'on a ensuite utilisé le
rapport du BRGM d'une autre façon alors
nous tenons à la disposition du scénario
le rapport on a aussi on a aussi rédigé
un communiqué de presse pour essayer de
préciser nous avons mis au point
PowerPoint pour résumer le rapport et
nous espérons que petit à petit le
contenu du rapport sera mieux compris ça
n'utilise pas le sujet des passifs
sur le sujet on n'a pas non plus regardé
la rentabilité vous voyez de la
construction de ses bassines parce
qu'évidemment si on est construit encore
faut-il pouvoir les remplir parce que
sinon ça sera ça sert à rien du tout et
remplir posé la question des seuils qui
est qui est des seuils à partir duquel
on autorise ou pas les prélèvements et
ça fait partie des choses sur lesquelles
pareil nous travaillons assez peu pour
le moment et finalement un des anges et
on aimerait travailler un des enjeux du
problème et là on a on a des seuils
partout
des seuils de niveau de nappe à partir
duquel le remplissage est autorisé ou
interdit et on a des cas où on a des
seuils qui sont parfois étonnants on va
dire en fait on voudrait on voudrait
beaucoup travailler sur les seuils sur
les modèles enfin pour un établissement
de recherche comme eldergm il y a
beaucoup de choses très intéressantes
très intéressant donc il vous faut plus
de moyens
sur ce sujet dans notre compte mais
c'est vrai que je pense que les moyens
de recherche qui ont été mis sur ce type
de questions sont peut-être pas comme à
la hauteur des enjeux qu'on va avoir
dans les prochaines décennies
nous sommes là pour vous écouter
justement et c'est d'analyser comment on
peut avancer de manière qualitative
après il y a toujours des arbitrages
mais on est bien d'accord
je vais poursuivre peut-être
dans l'avancée donc du bergm on a abordé
un peu ces cette montée en puissance
effectivement juridique un des éléments
aussi factuels et d'actualité c'est
l'évolution de la qualité aussi des
nappes et des nappes superficielles
aujourd'hui qui nous inquiète
particulièrement et nous inquiète aussi
parce que le spectre d'observation
jusqu'à maintenant était ce qu'il était
mais quand on l'élargit on s'aperçoit
qu'on a de plus en plus de polluants qui
étaient inconnus hier et qui doivent
nous inquiéter aujourd'hui donc je
suppose que vous avez aussi un regard
particulier sur le sujet
côté qualité de qualité des nappes c'est
de son bien sûr les pesticides qu'on
détecte le plus et on constate donc ça
ne se ralentit pas quand même la
contamination par les par les pesticides
les polluants plus émergents comme les
résidus de médicaments ou les perflux
oreilles sont des polluants sur lesquels
nous avons pour l'instant moins de
données et surtout moins de séries
longues donc ça commence mais pour
l'instant il n'y a pas de il n'y a pas
de valeur limite de seuil sur ces
polluants mais c'est une problématique
qui est fortement montante autre chose
qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que une
bonne partie des nappes en France sont
des nappes très inertiales et que quel
que soit les décisions qu'on prenne
aujourd'hui et certaines notes qui en
prend plusieurs centaines d'années pour
effacer les molécules qui sont présentes
c'est ça aussi quoi nécessaire d'avoir
ça en tête il y a
enfin tout ça pour dire c'est pas parce
qu'on prend des décisions aujourd'hui
que que forcément même si on fait mieux
si pour les pesticides typiquement dans
les nappes comme la nappe de la craie
qui est la plus inertielle dans une des
plus inertiales de surface qu'on a en
France si demain on demandait où par
exemple aux agriculteurs mais mais pas
que c'est pas les seuls à
occasionner des substances polluantes
d'arrêter tout traitement on aura encore
des progressions donc des augmentations
des niveaux de de contaminant pendant
plusieurs dizaines d'années
voilà donc c'est c'est toute la
difficulté aujourd'hui est aussi de
savoir
dans ce qu'on retrouve dans la nappe
aujourd'hui quand est-ce que ça a été
quand est-ce que ça a été pendu quand
est-ce que ça a été déversé et alors ça
le fait techniquement par exemple on
sait calculer les âges de l'eau mais
voilà c'est des c'est un sujet qui est
encore une fois très complexe et dans un
autre domaine cette fois-ci sur
l'unité qu'on a arrêté totalement les
engrais on mettrait un siècle et demi
avant de respecter les normes
européennes ou débouchés des bouchers
simplement il y a un décalage entre le
moment où on met les mesures et le
moment on observe les résultats malgré
tout le monde agricole fait des efforts
je dis simplement que comme les nappes
on leur inertie et on leur vitesse et
bien entre le moment où on résout un
problème et c'est lui mais on constate
qu'il n'y a plus de problèmes du tout
pour pour des
usagers c'est cool un temps qui peut
être long
est-ce qu'il faut
rouge c'est que c'est parfait merci
bonjour je suis arrivé un petit peu en
retard au début de l'audition donc je ne
sais pas si vous l'avez évoqué toutes
les
réflexions les observations que vous
faites je voulais savoir si aujourd'hui
il y avait des éléments de Copa de
comparaison internationale sur le fait
de réinjecter dans les nappes ou dans
les est-ce qu'on a ou en Europe est-ce
que vous avez des données enfin des
éléments de comparaison pour est-ce que
la recherche elle est elle est propre à
ce que vous faites en France ou est-ce
qu'on a des éléments au niveau
international
travaillons parfois aussi à
l'international par exemple on travaille
pour la ville du Cap
national sur la recharge il existe
d'autres pays qui sont plus avancés que
nous je pense en Israël ils sont très
avancés
avant nous c'est en Espagne typiquement
en Espagne typiquement voilà et dans le
compte dans un contexte toujours un peu
contraint en termes d'effectif est-ce
qu'on il faut consacrer nos effectifs à
faire de la recherche académique est-ce
qu'il faut faire de la recherche pour
les collectivités locales ou est-ce
qu'il faut aller à l'international
avec des hydrogéologues modalisateurs
qui sont très sollicités je réponds pas
souvent au BRGM qu'un international nous
allons apprendre des choses aussi qu'on
pourra ensuite réimporter en France dans
la situation ce sera compliqué et pour
compléter la réponse d'un point de vue
européen on profite c'est régulièrement
des programmes interags qui nous permet
de travailler avec de labos allemands
hollandais par le passé anglais l'année
dernière
se termine et puis au sud avec l'Italie
l'Espagne donc on a plusieurs plusieurs
programmes de recherche dans lequel on
collabore avec des laboratoires
européens
qui sont faites à l'étranger pour savoir
comment nous nous positionne
ça peut être un élément pour mieux
partager la connaissance et peut-être un
sujet à travailler je t'en prie Florence
bonjour et merci beaucoup peut-être une
question sur les justement la recherche
de substances qu'on recherche encore peu
aujourd'hui
notamment les substances médicamenteuses
perturbateurs endocriniens est-ce que
vous pensez qui peut être utile quand
même d'accélérer vu le temps de latence
dans les nappes et est-ce qu'on peut
avoir des éléments
comparatifs en fonction des systèmes
d'épuration il y a des systèmes par
membrane qui semble aujourd'hui plus
déjà je voudrais pas mettre une
meilleure épuration donc parce que bon
c'est aussi dans la mesure où les
collectivités investissent il faut dès
lors aller à mon avis au plus vite pour
que les investissent sur des systèmes
qui sont les plus efficients donc est-ce
qu'on a des éléments sur cela les
systèmes d'assainissement et le les
substances qui sont réellement filtrées
je veux je vais laisser pierre panner
répondre sur les aspects techniques mais
il faut pas oublier que le bergère est
un établissement public sous tut sujet
principal du Ministère de la Recherche
et tuta du ministère d'écologie et on
nous demande pas de décider de faire des
recherches à telle ou tel endroit on
nous dit vous allez faire une recherche
à telle ou tel endroit mais c'est nous
nous
obéissons en quelque sorte oui nous ne
sommes pas nous n'avons pas pouvoir de
décision sur la nature de nos recherches
sauf sur quelques crédits où nous
pouvons faire de la recherche sur entre
guillemets nos ressources propres nous
avons quelques moyens que nous faisons
nous essayons d'exploiter ça mais ça
reste limité par rapport à ce que nous
pouvons faire
techniquement
je vais pas vous mentir c'est un sujet
que je maîtrise vraiment pas beaucoup et
pour une raison simple c'est que le
Bergen travaille très peu sur
l'assainissement finalement le bergère
travaille sur la ressources du sol et du
sous-sol et finalement ce qui se passe
en recyclage et on est beaucoup moins
présent ceci dit on travaille quand même
pas mal avec les collectivités avec des
délégataires de service public qui
gèrent à la fois l'alimentation en eau
mais aussi l'assainissement
et ce qu'il y a de sûr c'est
qu'aujourd'hui il est fondamental
d'avoir une meilleure connaissance des
polluants dit émergents ou des héliciter
les médicamentseux et Madame reçoit
citer les perfus aurait qu'on appelle
enfin aujourd'hui les pie face on entend
beaucoup parler ça ça sort ces derniers
temps dans les médias ça fait quelques
temps qu'on travaille dessus quelques
temps qu'on commence à les connaître et
ce sont des éléments notamment les pifas
qui ont une très faible voir une
dégradation quasi impossible donc il est
vraiment nécessaire d'améliorer la
connaissance après quand on parle des
systèmes d'assainissement oui il y a
beaucoup de choses qui se font en osse
dans un ce genre de choses comme ça qui
au passage ont quand même du coup filtre
l'eau de tous les éléments qui nous
nourrissent de tous les selles donc
c'est pas forcément une bonne chose mais
surtout même si ça reste une solution la
meilleure solution reste encore de
limiter au maximum les les
contaminants qu'on a dans les eaux
brutes donc nous ce que nous pensons
c'est que la recherche doit être même si
un moment il est évident que pour qu'on
ait de l'eau propre robinet il faut il
faut il faut penser à toutes les
solutions y compris les solutions
curatives mais la prévention sur sur
l'origine de ces polluants comment ils
se comportent et quel est leur et leur
cycle de dégradation donc la prévention
reste pour nous le meilleur
investissement à faire pour qu'on ait de
l'eau propre et pérenne Anne robinet
dans la dans les
vers le futur
de la ressource c'est chez nous par
contre tout ce qui est curatif non ça
pour le coup ce sera pas fait par le par
le BRGM
alors ce au-delà bien sûr des modèles
qui sont à développer de plus en plus ce
qui nous intéresserait le plus ce serait
pour la partie pour les prélèvements
dans les nappes qu'on demande de nous
adresser des prélèvements localisés
j'entends bien sur une base mensuelle en
nous indiquant dans quel aquifère on
prélève à peu près à quel profondeur et
non pas sur une base annuelle comme
c'est le cas à l'heure actuelle on
aurait récupérons les données des
agences de l'eau mais qui sont des
données fiscales voilà ça ça coûterait
pas grand chose puisque les prélèvements
ils sont faits juste d'envoyer les
données sur une base mensuelle et nous
pourrions bien sûr préparer ce qu'il
faut pour que les données puissent être
envoyées de façon quasi automatique ça
dépend de la qualité du référentiel
aussi aujourd'hui sur les points de de
prélèvement voilà mais qui se sont
améliorés en ce qui concerne les points
les points d'eau comment on les appelle
on ça on a à peu près mais mais par
contre nous n'avons pas les données nous
avons juste les données annuelles et
c'est très dommageable pour pour
justement construire les modèles bien
entendu et les caler
quand on voit de gros écarts est-ce que
c'est le modèle qui est pas bon ou
est-ce que ce sont les prélèvements en
fait qui sont complètement
erronés c'est une bonne question il y
aura clairement pas de modèle fiable
tant qu'on a pas de données prémment
fiable à des pas de temps précis et ça
c'est fondamental une autre chose qui
pourrait être envisagée c'est tous les
gestionnaires de l'eau qui ont parfois
leur propre réseau de suivi intègrent
leurs données dans les bases de données
nationales en particulier Hadès qui est
la base de nationale de gestion des eaux
et puis vous posez une question sur les
éventuellement d'aller rechercher de
l'eau plus en profondeur même si on a
répondu dans le sens que c'est pas
forcément une bonne idée mais dans le
cas où quelqu'un aurait si si mettrait
quand même aujourd'hui la loi est quasi
nulle sur le sujet c'est à dire que il y
a deux mots dans la loi sur mes
voilà ça nécessite des des éléments de
protection beaucoup plus importants que
ce qui est maintenant dans la loi
ou presque dans la loi
très bien écoutez merci beaucoup bien
évidemment le but du jeu c'est ce qu'on
dit toujours au niveau des auditions on
n'a pas forcément abordé tous les sujets
que vous auriez souhaité poser sur la
table donc nous sommes preneur aussi de
réponse complémentaires et au cours de
l'audition de la mission puisque
celle-ci devrait se terminer fin juillet
s'il y a des sujets que vous souhaitez
porter un autre connaissance n'hésitez
pas le but du jeu c'est d'essayer
d'agréger le plus de sujets et de
questions voilà merci de votre écoute
merci beaucoup à vous deux
simplement je voulais vous remercier
pour vos dispositions et les
informations que vous venez de nous
livrer merci beaucoup
bon courage